[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
today's guest is dr gabor mate you can
find him online at dr gaboramate.com
that's
g-a-b-o-r-m-a-t-e.com on twitter at dr
dr gabor mate on instagram
gabramatemd
dr mate is a renowned speaker and
best-selling author he's been on the
podcast before and it was a very popular
episode he is highly sought after for
his expertise on a range of topics that
include addiction stress and childhood
development dr mate has written several
best-selling books including the
award-winning in the realm of hungry
ghosts i highly recommend subtitle close
encounters with addiction
when the body says no exploring the
stressed disease connection and
scattered how attention deficit disorder
originates and what you can do about it
he has also co-authored hold on to your
kids why parents need to matter more
than peers his works have been published
internationally in nearly 30 languages
his new book is the myth of normal
subtitle trauma illness and healing in a
toxic culture
gabor welcome back to the show it's nice
to see you
tim it's very nice to be back with you i
thought we would start with a little
ketchup because we haven't connected in
some time and i would love to just hear
how you are spending your time
in the last whether it's year or two i
know it's hard to
normalize things perhaps pun intended
with the subject matter
over covid but
how are you allocating your time these
days
actually kovid if i may say so
personally did me a favor because i had
this book to write
and
it was a much
bigger project than i even had imagined
and
i had all these
travel commitments which fortunately i
had to cancel which allowed me to stay
at home and
finish the book which took me a year
longer than i expected it so the last
three years have been pretty much
dominated by book writing
but and because of kovic i've been doing
a lot of teaching online
a lot of webinars
now that i'm free again i'll are doing
extensive traveling one more time and
then
with the book lunch as well of course
the most exciting thing that happened to
me if i can jump right into it was jump
right in
three weeks ago i participated in a
plant ceremony
with some indigenous canadians here in
british columbia
they invited me to come and
help support their healing process
and i'm telling it to him it was a
life-changing experience
being with these indigenous folks on
their land
you may have heard the delegation of
canadian indigenous leaders went to the
vatican
where the pope issued a very
to my mind paltry apology for the
suffering that had been inflicted on
generations of canadian native children
in these residential schools where they
were tormented and sexually physically
abused spiritually suppressed they died
in large numbers their bodies are just
being discovered now
so
working with these people the suffering
and the sorrow and the sadness and the
pain
is unfathomable
but the dignity the beauty the
connection to nature the
honoring of spirit the welcome the love
the
resilience was also just absolutely
humbling to behold so
i died i went there to help them but i
got helped more than
i think i gave it was a profound
profound experience so i'm still glowing
with it uh three or four weeks later so
that's what's formed up to my mind these
days is is how to
embody and apply those teachings
in my own life but also in my work
well i would love to stay on that for a
little bit because
you mentioned something that only
recently
came to my attention i was actually in
new hawk tribe territory
about six to eight weeks ago
and learned for the first time of these
mass graves
and much of the history that you're
describing which is
horrifying of course and the ripple
effects of that carry over
well into
today in the case of this particular
ceremony this medicine experience i know
you have and for people listening if
they don't have the context you have
a lot of exposure and experience with
use of different
medicines including but not limited to
psychedelics within that including but
not limited to ayahuasca for instance
in this particular case was it a sort of
a syncretic blend of
indigenous first nations practices and
then
[Music]
plants or otherwise that are used in in
other places it was a plant that goes
here locally and
uh even though there's no
artifactual
evidence of them having used this plant
before
but when they used it they said it's in
their dna it feels so familiar to them
and it's hard to imagine that they
wouldn't have used it traditionally
because
they know every plant every blade of
grass
every leaf every
bud every flower the medicinal uses
of
everything i mean the connection to
nature is beyond belief so
it's also beyond belief
that they would not have known about
you know the plant that we used which
goes on their land
and again it felt so familiar to them so
for them it wasn't the question of
something foreign coming in it was
something
very much aligned with their own
experience
what i brought to it was sort of western
psychology and my capacity to ask the
right questions and to
delve into the
traumatic imprints that they carry
because of this tragic history but
it was very much in line with their own
traditions so a few follow-up questions
related to that and you can feel free of
course as with all of my questions to
not answer those that you don't want to
but yeah
in the case of the plant is that
something you can
describe more specifically is that
something that you prefer not to mention
no there's mushrooms mushrooms yeah yeah
so
yeah you would have to imagine
like you mentioned given the sheer
density of sort of philosophy mushrooms
in that region that
they would have had experience yeah
almost certainly now it's like peyote
and southern
western areas of the united states you
know it's it's a plant that was well you
know how would they not know given that
they know every other plant
what was your unfolding or the
experience why why do you think it was
impactful for you personally
well first of all the context
because i'm with people that are just so
honest and so raw and so
open
and so welcoming
so that
i've never felt more at home with any
group of people even though i never met
any of them personally before
so there was that
that was the experience and and we all
had to utter some words before the
ceremony about what our intentions were
and i heard two words love and presence
then i experienced them both
i experienced
love
from myself in a deep way which was new
for me actually
i can't put it into words because it's
not a concept it's not a
intellectual exercise it was actually an
experience a full body experience is
what it was
and yeah i experienced presence
and
it's
you've had these experiences that
they're ineffable they're
they're they're almost you take a a poet
somebody with a much more poetic
imagination than i have to to actually
somehow depict it in words
but i i tell you i came out of it
and then i sat on the porch outside it
was a beautiful sunny evening we're
looking at this beautiful mountain
here in british columbia there were
bison in the field below us
and
and this of course in in the native
experience or imagination everything has
a story so the mountain itself is a
story
you know so i'm looking at this
beautiful mountain and this bison and
the sunset and
nobody had to convince me that
nature
contains us all
you know
not at that moment anyway
it's for people who have not
heard any of your backstory this
first-hand experience of love that you
mentioned is not being
let's just say a common experience for
you
maybe it's worth just for a second
rewinding if you wouldn't mind
just sharing a bit of
why that is in our first conversation
you told the story and perhaps you could
just fill in some of the gaps of growing
up in or certainly being born in hungary
having relatives perish in the holocaust
and then even after the deportation of
jews had stopped jews were still still
being persecuted and
if i recall correctly murdered by sort
of the fascists who were
in power at that time
and you were handed off to your mother
handed you off to someone else because
she wasn't sure if she would survive is
that am i remembering that correctly
well let me tell you a story around this
so sometimes after i met you i went to
peru to take to lead
a retreat
for
medical people
with the plant ayahuasca
and
when i say i lead the retreat i don't
lead the ceremonies i don't hand out
the brew i help people formulate
intentions beforehand and integrate
experiences afterwards
but these people 23 people came from all
over the world health professionals
doctors psychiatrists psychologists to
work with me in this
jungle setting
with native healers
so
i did the work the first day went really
well then we had the ceremony the first
night now my experience with ceremonies
is that everybody else has deep
ceremonies and i don't because i have
this very thick skull and just nothing
gets through you know that's my
little self myth you know so these shoe
people native
maestros and maestras
shamans
sit down in front of me in turn and each
of them and each of them chats to
everybody so there were 24 of us
each of them gets chanted to six times
in turn by each of these maestro's
meisters they sit down in front of me
and i say okay do your worst you know
and very little happened for me
next morning they sent a delegation to
me
they said we can't have you in ceremony
because you have such a dark dense
energy in you
that this is affecting everybody else
so it interferes in our in our ikaros
our chance can't penetrate
your darkness
furthermore they said
we can't even have you working with your
people during the day because you're
still be affecting them
so they fired me from my own ceremony
for my own retweet literally
they had no idea they were not impressed
with the fact that i've written books or
published in how many languages or any
any of that they didn't own my
reputation they just know i'm this guy
from the north doctor you know
and they said here's what happened to
you
we think you've worked with so many
traumatized people that you've absorbed
their traumas and you haven't cleared it
out of yourself
and furthermore they said we think when
you're very small you're the big scare
and you haven't got over it yet
the first chapter opens with the
painting that my wife did of me as an
infant this is from a photograph
looking at a camera
with absolute terror in my face
and a pediatrician who came to see me
when i was separated from my mother at a
year age
she said she'd never seen such terror in
the eyes of a human being
as she saw in my little eyes
now these shamans picked that up like
that
and what they said was we're gonna
assign one of you to work with you alone
because we want to heal you so i had
five private ceremonies with a shaman
all to me
and it ended beautifully
but when you talk about that early scare
that i had
these people picked up on it
instantaneously
and this
maestro
chanted to me over five nights
three or four hours five hours
and by god he cleared so much out of me
i couldn't even believe it at the end do
you think at some point we will be able
to and i'm not saying this
needs to happen certainly it doesn't for
the therapeutic effects to be seen
do you think the kind of rationalist
physicalist western
scientific perspective will find some
type of
explanation for what you're describing
if we assume for the time being that
that something is in fact happening it's
not purely placebo effect i mean even if
it is that's something but do you do you
think there will be a point
at any
juncture in the near future where we'll
have some explanatory
capabilities
so
what's frustrating for me
and not just for me by the way
is that we have so much science already
to explain such experiences
and uh
many more amazing healing experiences we
actually have the western science to
prove it or to explain it and what's
frustrating is what's been called the
science practice gap
where
on the one hand we have the science
but the science hasn't penetrated
the medical practice consciousness
there's a gap between not only
western medicine and traditional
understandings
but there's even a gap between western
science
and western medical practice in so many
ways
so in terms of my own experience
there are certain traumatic imprints
that are ingrained
in the emotional circuits of my brain
in the
very basic
survival mechanisms of my brain in my
lower parts of my brain
and uh
these are
neurological circuits
embedded with a certain kind of
experience and a certain kind of
belief and a certain kind of reactive
pattern
so
the belief that i'm impenetrable
and everybody else can heal but i can
lead other people to healing but i can't
get there myself
that itself is an imprint of trauma
because
an infant or a small child being
traumatized they think it's gonna go on
forever
and then
that experience
of being in the moment and not seeing an
end to it then becomes a belief
so then i take that belief into the
ceremony
and i sit there and i'm saying do your
worst you can't get through this brain
in other words i'm sabotaging my own
experience not meaning to
but that's why i'm imprinted
now these people don't buy my story
they see through to the fear
in fact they even intuit the experience
that it must have been a very early
scare that i had
so this guy just
holds me like a father
and he loves me and he chants to me
and it's almost sometimes like a
lullaby being sung to a baby
well guess what a sense of safety arises
in me
and when the safety arises my whole
visceral body experience changes
my heart my breathing
my intestines
my muscles
they're all in the different state
much more receptive
and this goes on for five nights
and by the end of it
i come out
a different person
now when i say i come at a different
person believe me i travel home
and all of a sudden that different
person becomes a memory
and
you know i have to struggle again with a
lot of the same old stuff but i'm
struggling with them from a much more
informed perspective
and um i know it's no longer my absolute
reality
which is a huge difference
seems like all the difference it's not
that hard to understand really
yeah because we know that the brain
can develop new circuits and new ways of
understanding
in response to new experiences
was that five nights just just so i
understand that was that was five
consecutive nights of drinking each
night yourself
or were you not drinking on each day
five nights over ten days so we had a
ceremony and then we had a day of rest
when i would just meditate and do my
yoga and walk the jungle the the rain
the rainforest paths and uh and read my
spiritual books and contemplate
and then back into ceremony so yeah it
was a 10-day private retweet it's what i
ended up having
yeah
and the rest of them worked directly to
the group
sounds like everybody won in that
situation
everybody won
and let me tell you an interesting
aftermath
so
afterwards
the shamans told me that when they knew
that
24
you know healers you know doctors
psychologists psychiatrists are coming
from the west they thought we'd have an
easy job because they said
we absorb a lot of trauma from other
people as well but we cleared out of
ourselves
so we expected you would have done the
same thing
and they said they've never looked at
such a heavy bunch of people in their
whole lives
than these western doctors
because we work with all these
traumatized people all the time
we don't even understand trauma let
alone do we know how to clear it out of
ourselves so they had a big job on their
hands the shamans
and
those people that participated had a
huge experience and when they went back
to their work
so many of them it changed completely
do you think there will be a point maybe
you already can where you can yourself
do that self
care of clearing whatever you may
absorb
uh so to speak by say patience in a
clinical practice
i'm doing it now i have to like i i in
the course of my work what do you do oh
well i do uh meditation practice
actually when i learned from one of my
colleagues dr daniel siegel who's got
this wheel of awareness
that i'm practicing
i have a yoga practice that i do pretty
much every day now
every day i go swimming i swim 2k every
day or or do some other kind of workout
and um
i pay a lot more attention
to my own needs than i used to
the yoga is that still i think last time
we spoke this some time ago so maybe
it's changed but saad guru based is it
uh is it still that or is it something
else
no it's his yoga i don't want to
particularly tie it to his particular
personality with which i have some
issues
concerns
i just don't like hero worship or guru
worship of any kind
but yeah the yoga i learned through his
course has been very helpful to me
so let's dive into the new book you've
written many books
you've certainly i would imagine thought
of
many possible books you could write why
spend multiple years
on this one
tim i hadn't thought of multiple books
that i could have written this is the
one that's been calling me and yelling
at me for the last 10 12 years and
literally took 10 years of research
in fact
very many times i thought i wasn't up
for it i thought it was too big i
thought this time
there's an expression of a hungarian in
hungarian which goes uh having struck
your axe into a very big tree you know
like this time you've taken on too much
you know
and many times
believe me i
i even had the contract for the book
five six years ago and i gave the money
back i said i can't do it it's too much
for me
but it just kept calling me and calling
me and calling me and then one day it
just woke up and said okay
i'm here you got to do it and that's
when the new title came to me and
that's when i started working on it
again and so here it is but so it's it's
been a calling it's really been calling
me i can't put it in the way nothing
else has been calling me this has been
calling me
so that's why i did it how does that
show up for you is it like insomnia that
it's
ideas that are coming to your mind how
does how does that calling i'd just love
to know how that actually shows up or
manifests for you
well
excitement
yeah i i want to do this
there's a visceral knowledge that
there's something right about this
when i say there's something right about
it i don't mean that i'm correct about
everything i say or i just mean write
for me
that this is what i need to do
the
when i see a newspaper article where i
see a new book title right away
oh yeah
this speaks to us i gotta read that
article i have to read that book
so the world keeps
feeding me
information that demands to be
metabolized
and synthesized
and written and spoken
and then over the last few years you
know
as
we've seen crisis upon crisis
it just occurs to me
somebody's gonna write about
how life in this system affects the
health of human beings
and
so
it's visual excitement it's ideas it's
information that just keeps pouring at
me like a lava flow
and this just is
coupled with the fear that i'm not big
enough to do this you know
[Music]
so it's a combination of a lot of things
but even that fear that i'm not big
enough to do this
is
assigned to me of the importance of what
i'm talking about when i say the
importance i don't mean to
be grandiose i mean the importance to me
if it was not important i wouldn't be so
afraid of it
that's what i mean
maybe we can launch into a story i have
a few cues here yeah jumping off points
in front of me
and tell me if if this makes any sense
as a direction to go
and what i have in front of me is the
story of how trauma can inflict and
affect everyday life story of landing in
the airport
would you like to grab that baton and
run with it
well sure and this relates to what i was
what you're asking me about before in
terms of my early history so this is
when i was 72
six years ago
i'd been on a speaking trip to
philadelphia i spoken on
addiction
the link that i draw between
childhood trauma and addiction as you
and i have talked about this
it was well received on the way back air
canada
bumps me up to first class so i couldn't
be more comfortable i land at the
airport
my wife is meant to pick me up and i get
a text as i land saying i haven't left
home yet do you still want me to come
and from feeling very comfortable and
very pleased with myself if i can put it
that way i go into a rage i just
and i text back never mind
and i take the taxi home
so imagine the indignity of having to
take a taxi home you know and i arrive
home
now here's the deal my wife's an artist
when she's in the studio painting
everything else disappears
i've only known this for over 50 years
you see
she has no she has no bladder she has no
husband
she has no
hunger that's just her and the art
and that's what happened you know so
so what am i so upset about when i come
home i don't even talk to her
i just grunt at her
and uh
i keep this up for a day and she finally
says
knock it off already
and as i say
it's a tribute
to
decades of progress that i could knock
it off after 24 hours because in the
past i might have carry on for days like
that now what's that all about
well my mother gave me to a stranger as
you mentioned earlier and i didn't see
her for five or six weeks when i was a
year old she did this to save my life
when i saw her again i didn't even look
at her for several days
and that's what small children do on
separation because the brain says
that it was so hurt when you abandoned
me
that i'll never open myself up again to
that kind of vulnerability i won't even
look at you
now that imprint from a year old
is what showed up
when my wife said i'm not picking you up
or at least i'd be late picking you up
all of a sudden the woman on whom i'm
relying for presence and support and
love
is unavailable
and what gets triggered is just
childhood imprint of abandonment and
rage and despair
and so this is how trauma shows up in
our lives
it doesn't have to be as dramatic as
that but it shows up in our
relationships and how we feel about
ourselves in how we interpret events
and how we react to things that happen
in our world view
so trauma is this sort of invisible
dynamic
that shapes so much of how we live our
lives but we tend not to be aware of it
and until we become aware of it
it can run our lives it can run our
personal lives it can also run our
politics in our culture
so let me come back to
the rage for a second because i would
love to get your
advice or at least hear of some of your
learnings over the last
decades because i recall from our first
conversation
that
you know in your 40s your successful
doctor
you're driven workaholic you had
challenges in your marriage your kids
were at least based on my notes afraid
of you at points because of your rages
right what have you
learned about rage and anger how do you
relate to it or metabolize it and i ask
as someone who has a long history of
[Music]
running on
anger as a maybe a corrosive fuel of
sorts so i would i would love to just
hear you expand on that in any way that
makes sense
so there was a great neuroscientist his
name was yak pancek pnk scpp
who tragically died a few years ago of
cancer
and he distinguished a number of brain
systems that we share with other mammals
they include
care he capitalized these so you see a
are care
then something
he calls grief and panic
then
fear
lust
seeking
play
and rage
these are all brain systems that we have
they're all necessary for mammalian life
they're all necessary
another by raging means
the anger that arises when our
boundaries are being transgressed
if i were to
infringe on your boundaries either
physically
or emotionally
the
healthy response for you
is to mount an anger response
no get out
stay away
that's healthy
healthy anger is in the moment
it protects your boundaries
and then it's gone
it's not necessary anymore
however
if your boundaries were infringed as a
child
but you could not express it
it doesn't disappear
it gets suppressed
it becomes almost like a volcano that's
gurgling and and and bubbling inside you
but it's had no expression
now why did you suppress it because
if you're being
well are you being very public about
this so i'm sure you'll allow me to
mention it but you've
sometime after
you and i talked you actually publicly
acknowledged that you'd been sexually
abused as a child
yeah it did
now
when that's happening to a small child
the last thing you can afford
is to is to be angry
because if you get rageful
at the boundary invasion
you're going to get hurt even more
so suppressing that rage becomes a
survival mechanism
nothing wrong with it it's the right
thing to do
you don't do it your brain will do it
for you automatically as a way of
preserving your life or your your
relative safety
but the rage doesn't go away
what happens then later on as an adult
something triggers you
and also it just explodes out of you
and you have no control over it
now it's no longer a response
a healthy response to the present moment
but it's a response to the past and just
as my
hurt and sense of abandonment and enrage
was triggered by my wife not picking me
up at the airport
so a person's rage can be triggered by
something relatively minor
but all of a sudden this
lava flow just explodes out of you
and
the difference between healthy anger and
by the way suppressing healthy anger is
also unhealthy for you we can talk about
that but
just as healthy anger
expresses itself does its job and then
it's gone
rage the way such as i'm describing such
as the way i used to experience it and
probably as used to experience it
the more it explodes the bigger it gets
that's what happens to me it doesn't
pass through me sorry no i was just
reinforcing that by saying you know i've
i've worked with certain therapists
who've said you know punch a pillow
express the rage let it just pass
through you like the wind but that isn't
in fact what happens with me and i know
i'm not the only one it actually
magnifies and intensifies and extends
this feeling exactly because it recruits
more brain circuits into its service
so that's the difference between
healthy anger on one hand which is an
essential boundary defense
and by the way so much parenting advice
in this culture
tells parents
to force kids to suppress their anger
really unhealthy advice
and um
there's healthy anger then there's that
rage that you and i have both
experienced
that
to work with that
no it's
look if you're gonna punch a human being
and there's a pillow to punch instead
better to punch the pillow
right no question about that but there's
a technique of dealing with it no that's
not how you learn to
process that rage because it needs to be
processed
how do you approach
the processing what is a more effective
prescription or one possible way
of thinking about it or approaching it
well if i was working with you
i would encourage you to fully
experience the body experience of rage
what's happening in your body
and you'll find that it's not just an
idea in your head
it's
something that
dominates your visceral experience of
yourself
your muscles your breathing
your abdomen
your entire nervous system
and um
there's ways of just helping you
experience it
experience it by
recognizing raising the awareness of of
being with it now that there's a
wonderful buddhist
the lineage spiritual teacher meditation
teacher called tara brach who talks
about reign
recognize
allow
investigate and nurture
so you recognize oh yeah this is
happening in me right now
okay
i'm gonna allow it
not
along it in the sense of i'm gonna act
it out on somebody else
but i'm going to be with the experience
and then
investigate okay what is this really all
about
and then nurture that little person that
had to suppress all that rage it's a
nutshell
view of it but in other words there's
ways of working with it through the body
that doesn't involve either suppressing
it or acting it out
but in experiencing it
yeah i'll need to revisit uh tara
and range she's been very helpful to me
i just want to give her credit where
credit is due and maybe i mentioned this
in our first conversation as well
the
radical acceptance as a book
yeah
as a title it turned me off but a friend
of mine who is a very skeptical
neuroscience phd or has a phd in
neuroscience i should say
who's generally averse to anything that
even rhymes with woo-woo
read this book and recommended it to me
and i found it tremendously tremendously
helpful and it may be time for me to
revisit it
and you know she also tells this
apocryphal story
that
is
is
in some ways linked to this conversation
that we're having
she tells this apocryphal story of a
sage who says there's only one question
that really matters and that is what are
you unwilling to feel
and
you know because i've also had
therapists ask me like do you experience
clean anger and
my instinctive answer is no i don't
and i resist it because i view it as
potentially destructive especially the
way that it
can
feed on itself an amp and get amplified
and i'm not at risk of like throwing a
chair through a window or punching
someone so
because i've become very good at
suppression
but it's not lost on me that there's a
cost to be exacted when you do that yeah
by the way i've read radical acceptance
recently as well that's why it's in my
mind and
i'm also somebody that doesn't do
acceptance or surrender very well so
i resist those titles but you know what
i find it very helpful and very
compassionate actually and and from my
perspective from the point of view the
therapy that i teach my students
no part of us no aspects of us is bad so
that rage of yours
it came along for a good reason yeah and
the suppression of the rage
that came along for a good reason as
well and so the more we can investigate
this and understand it
the more we
can make friends with all aspects of
ourselves which i think is the key to
healing
by the way radical acceptance doesn't
mean radical tolerance it doesn't mean
that you put up with everything right
it just means that you
accept that this is the way it is right
now
now where do we go from here it's not a
question of okay
i'm going to accept all the injustice
and oppression and unfairness that's in
the world no it's not about that at all
that's a really really good
clarification
and it's at least as i recall the book i
should revisit it it's it's very much
focused also on
self-acceptance meaning acceptance of
the parts of us that we have disowned
including the emotions that we're not
willing to feel let me ask you
about and this is real this is all
related i suppose everything's related
at the end of the day but
what happens when one
seemingly non-negotiable need is pitted
against another so so the example i want
to ask you about specifically is
attachment versus authenticity right so
if i think about the the
the reaction i had to my significant
other this morning which was
similar to your
taxi experience
yeah
on one hand i wanted to
be very direct in how i was feeling and
then i
hesitated in expressing that which would
have come with a tone of anger almost
certainly
because i wanted
her acceptance and support didn't want
to hurt her and so i felt this
inner conflict
of needs that i couldn't reconcile and
maybe that's not the best example but
i would love for you to
sort of help
me and the listeners explore this a bit
because i can't be can't imagine i'm the
only one who experiences this type of
thing
i don't know
i wasn't there and i don't know what
happened but
my guess is that
you and i did this exercise once before
that you very uh i thought rather
bravely put on youtube
where we went through a certain
experience of yours so you haven't been
upset
the lesson from that exercise and i
imagine and very often
or take my reaction at the airport
and i imagine perhaps your reaction this
morning and i can't say this for sure
because i wasn't there
but very often we don't react to what
happens we react to an interpretation of
what happens right
so that your partner did or didn't say
or do
something
and then you had a certain
interpretation of that
and then you react to that
interpretation so i imagine that may
have happened
but
more generally speaking so then you're
in this dilemma if i
fully express who i feel i'm gonna
maybe hurt her and hurt the relationship
or hurt them and hurt their relationship
but if i
don't
then i'm not being authentic
so what do i do i mean i think that's
the dilemma that you're posing here it
goes back to very early in childhood
because we have these two needs that
i've identified one of them is for
attachment attachment being our need for
connection and closeness with another
person for the sake of being taken care
of
or for the sake of taking care of the
other
so when i talked about these brain
circuits of dr paksep the care system is
designed for you and i to take care of
the vulnerable
our young
our very old ones
our sick ones
there's a system in our brain with its
own brain chemicals and its own
circuits that are designed to help us
care for one another
that's essential from no mammal will
survive without that
we also
have a system for what he calls grief
and panic and that's what we experience
when we don't get that care
you know
so we're wired to attach for the sake of
survival and no creature is more
dependent
more vulnerable
more immature than a human infant
compared to any other animal
so our dependence is absolute so need to
attach is absolute
but we have another need
as creatures and then as human beings
which is to be authentic
now i don't need any kind of new age
who who concept by this i mean knowing
what we feel and being able to how to
act on what we feel so
you know as you know we evolved uh out
there in nature
how long does any creature
in nature survive if they don't know
what their gut feelings are telling them
not very long not very long that
authenticity which comes from the word
auto for self knowing ourselves
and manifesting ourselves is an also
essential need
that's fine
but what happens
if
a child experiences the emotions
that the environment says
won't accept you with that
that can happen through abuse
but it can also happen through
well-meaning parents who read the
parenting advice of a lot of experts
including some that i think you've heard
on your program
who who will tell you that when a kid is
angry they should be made to sit by
themselves wait let's name some names
here
who are we talking about jordan peterson
says that in his book twelves rules for
life
an angry child should be made to sit by
themselves until he says they come back
to normal in other words anger in a
child is not normal but he's not the
only one and the message to the child is
you're not acceptable when you have that
emotion
no
not a child is a dilemma
i can be authentic
but then they're gonna exclude me
if that's going to threaten my
attachment relationship
or i can suppress my authenticity
and then i'll have the attachment
now what do you think gets sacrificed
100 of the time authenticity the
authenticity gets sacrificed
and then we spent the rest of our lives
trying to figure out who the heck we are
and uh that suppression of authenticity
has
severe mental and physical health
implications
from autoimmune disease to malignancy to
depression
takes for example something like called
depression
what does it mean to depress something
literally what does it mean push down to
push it down
depression is not this inherited brain
disease
it's the result of having to push
oneself down push someone's emotions as
a child
just to play devil's advocate here i
mean there can be
and there are appear to be genetic
markers that predispose someone again
it's not predetermination but there
there is
it would seem a genetic component it's
not purely
in the absence of childhood events
something that does not occur right
would you say that is fair i'm going to
give you an argument on that one i mean
having written this book i've just
reviewed the literature
nobody's ever discovered the gene for
any mental health condition
nor have you ever discovered any group
of genes that cause any mental health
condition
nobody has discovered
any group of genes that if you have them
you're going to get this disease
nobody's group has any discovered any
group of genes that if you don't have
them you can't get this condition
what people have discovered
is there's a large group of genes
that the more than we have the more
likely you might have
any number of mental health conditions
from adhd to depression to psychosis to
whatever but none of them code for the
specific condition
so something is being inherited yes
but what is being inherited
and
you you take animals or human beings
with those same set of genes and you
give them different environments they'll
turn out to be very different creatures
some of them will be extremely
functional
if they were treated very well
so what is being inherited then now this
is contrary to the medical mantra i'm
telling you the science
okay what is being inherited are not
diseases what is being inherited is
sensitivity
the more sensitive you are
and you and i talked about sensitivity
the first time you met but let's just
illustrate it if i tap myself on the
shoulder right now i don't know if i did
this exercise last time last time i
don't feel any pain at all do i
but what if i
what if my shoulder was bare and there
was a burn there so my nerve endings
were close to the surface
which means i was thin skinned
and now i touch myself with the same
force
now what do i feel severe pain
so
sensitivity from the latin word sincere
just means to feel the more sensitive
you are genetically
the more you feel
the more you feel when things go wrong
the more pain you have the more pain you
have the more you have to get defenses
around that pain and all mental health
conditions reflect some defense against
pain
in fact so there are many physical
conditions so what i'm saying is yes
there's some genetic component here
but that's not a disease that's being
inherited it's sensitivity and therefore
vulnerability that's being inherited
from there on it depends purely on the
environment
sure i think we're
largely on the same page the point i
just wanted to make is that there are
predispositions it's not
a binary
[Music]
transmission of a disease although those
may exist with things like pompe disease
and so on if you have two recessive
carriers but let me come back to
attachment versus authenticity for one
second because in the case of this child
who's expressing say
anger
and if there are people who would take
the stance of
the prescriptive move is to put that
child in the corner until they come back
to their senses
in that case
the child is going to choose attachment
over authenticity and you condition the
child to behave that way
how would you handle that situation
right because i suppose if if i wanted
to
sort of stand in for some people
listening and for myself frankly
if you don't help a child to learn to
regulate themselves in some fashion you
just end up with someone who can't
function
in society or if they're encouraged to
kind of
indulges a strong word but embrace every
impulse that they have with a strong
emotion
they'll probably in some way get
exiled by their
students and
peers also so how do you how do you walk
that tightrope how do you suggest
handling that type of circumstance
i agree with you the
intent of good parenting or good
child-rearing is to help
the development of self-regulation
absolutely the question is how to get
there right no
it's not a question of everybody should
behave exactly how they want to and
held with everybody else you know
it can't be that that's permissiveness
that's not healthy parenting either
but it also depends what age we're
talking about like for example a
two-year-old
they want to cook you before dinner now
if you're doing your job as a parent
you're gonna frustrate them
because you're gonna say no cookie
before dinner
now what do we do as adults as mature
adults when we get frustrated
you know if we're lucky we know how to
handle all frustration
but if you're like me sometimes you'll
start
throwing a bit of a tantrum so that's
what a two-hero will do
they'll throw a tantrum nothing wrong
with the two-year-old throwing a tantrum
that's just what their brain is
programmed to do when they're frustrated
so you say oh you're really angry aren't
you
you really want that cookie yeah
and you're really mad at daddy because
he won't give you the cookie yeah
that allows the child to move through
the emotions and to know that emotions
can come and go
how self-regulation happens is as dr dan
siegel points out
is that the immature circuits of the
child's brain
use the mature circuits of the adult's
brain
of the nurturing adult's brain to help
regulate it
so the way you help a child
learn so or not learn but develop
self-regulation
is by being regulated
yourself so if you stay calm you say
you're really angry aren't you
that'll help the child develop
self-regulation
because he's downloading your circuits
but if you respond with punishment or
hostility and giving him the message
that he's just not acceptable
you're just frustrating him even more
you might get compliant behavior
but you're gonna get somebody whose rage
is being suppressed and we've already
talked about that and you're going to
get somebody who's going to get
depressed because they're pushing
themselves down
a child who's understood and held
and loved they'll move through these
emotions very quickly
very quickly
and that's how you learn self-regulation
is that these emotions can arise
and they'll go
and we're not to be attached to them
and we don't have to act them out
you know so
self-regulation
begins
by the adult world being regulated
and not reactive
yeah that makes a lot of sense
let's let's come back to the myth of
normal yeah and if you look back at your
many books and maybe maybe i'm just
unique in this
in this situation but i don't think i am
i'll explain what i mean
when i look back at each of my books
there are chapters or elements or
messages that i wish i'd maybe
emphasized more
or that i'm
sad
get
skipped over or not given enough
attention
in the new book are there any
chapters or concepts
anything at all that you really hope
people do not
miss i know that's perhaps a strange way
to phrase it but
i'll leave it there as a starting point
it's almost like i felt i could just
print the title the title page the myth
of normal
trauma illness and healing in a toxic
culture and just have people write their
own books you know
just have a bunch of empty pages
so i think the message is reinforced
through the whole book
what we think is normal in our society
from the point of view of human needs
and human evolution is absolutely
abnormal
and therefore what we think of
abnormalities in terms of illnesses and
and and dysfunctions and diseases and so
on
these are normal responses to abnormal
circumstances
and the biggest laws you and i already
talked about this is a society that from
the very beginning from in utero onwards
which stresses on human beings
that they lose contact with themselves
and the essence of trauma is loss of
contact with yourself loss of connection
to yourself
and that's reinforced through parenting
practices
the parenting advice people get you and
i already talked about that
it's reinforced in your school system
but it's all about competition and
evaluation
rather than
relaxation and learning
we're judged all the time by by our
externals like hobby look
what we achieve
how smart we are how fast we are we're
not accepted for who we are with our
flaws and our vulnerabilities
society caters to those false needs
so that
you know
for god's sakes people are botoxing
themselves
because they've learned that how they
are is just not acceptable
people are
on facebook presenting a false image of
themselves
because
they believe that how they are and who
they are is not good enough
we sold all these products and um
are
manipulated into all these activities
that are
all attempts to fulfill some deep hunger
in ourselves
that is missing because we've lost our
two cells
we are
manipulated
into buying products and eating foods
that are actually toxicly addictively
unhealthy
and this happens with the full awareness
event none of the awareness the
the employment of modern science
as to how to get people hooked on cell
phones or junk foods
our politics reflects
very traumatized people reaching the top
enacting policies that then create more
trauma for large numbers of people
now there is this is a society that
for all its wealth scientific ingenuity
incredible progress in science and and
medicine
has fundamentally got disconnected from
the essence of what it means to be human
beings and we suffer there's an article
in the new yorker about the alarming
rise in childhood suicide the mysterious
rise in child there's nothing mysterious
about it
kids are stressed
because of the conditions of this
culture all the lonely people as the
beatles sang you know
all the lonely people
the number of people lonely has doubled
in the last 30 years
britain has appointed a minister of
loneliness
loneliness kills
it's as dangerous as smoking 15
cigarettes a day
in terms of causing
illness or or potentiating illness and
death
ah there's so many ways in which this
culture is
abnormal
and it's causing people to be not well
and so
that message
that's the essential one that i hope
people won't miss but i i kind of doubt
that they will if they read the book
and the big message is tim is we don't
have to be that way it's not our true
nature
we've been sold a bill of goods about
what human nature is
human acre is not like that and
precisely the reason there's so much
dysfunction is because we've got
disconnect from our true nature we don't
have to be we can find our way back
we can embrace it
and we'll be a lot healthier both as a
group and as individuals
so what you're saying
reminds me of a
quote no doubt you've heard it many
maybe even used it many times this is
from krishnamurti it's no measure of
health to be well adjusted to a
profoundly sick society
yeah
and
my next question relates to
what to do
because i have noticed for myself for
instance if i'm
off in the mountains and the rivers or
the jungle by myself
for a period of time i come back
i feel better attuned i feel much
more at ease
there are all these positive effects but
it
at least in that form is opting out of
society now maybe that's okay
but
as i contemplate part of my reason for
asking about parenting and anger
management or recognition and so on is
because i'm
contemplating starting a family soon and
that's that's at least in the plans and
you know disappearing to the jungle for
months at a time may not be may or may
not be compatible with that
at least in the early stages so
recognizing the problem
what are some of the things that
people can do or what are questions they
should be asking how would you suggest
they start looking at
treatments or solutions
first of all i wouldn't be too quick to
dismiss the connection with nature
i do talk about
a woman called clara hughes and claire
hughes was the first person to win
medals at both the summer and winter
olympics she's a canadian
wonderful person and
after she retired from sports she became
a public speaker and
was just stressing herself fulfilling
all these demands
and then she decided to start walking so
every year for six months of the year
she just goes walks here she walks she's
walked from
i think northern canada to mexico you
know and she reconnects herself through
that wow
obviously nobody can do that all the
time claire doesn't have children so she
can afford to
to do that
but that doesn't mean that the
connection with nature needs to be
dismissed so i would say for you if
that's a powerful connection and a
way for you to reconnect with yourself
for god's just keep doing it you might
not do it for as long and as intensively
as you might before your children but
keep it up because it's an essential
part of who you are
but beyond that
what keeps us disconnected from
ourselves
are the imprints of trauma
and uh
i suggest ways of working that through
that's not the only way i'm certainly no
not unique in offering pathways to
wholeness as i call it that part of the
book
but
people need to realize to what extent
their tensions and their unhappiness and
the dysfunctions things that they don't
like about themselves
they all came along for a reason
at some point they had a function to
play
no they're no longer helpful we can work
them through you got to get help
either through reading the right books
and or finding the right therapist
and or engaging in the right kind of
spiritual practice
or
martial arts
or something but there's always the way
to work it through i can't emphasize
enough the importance of communality of
connection
we're wired to connect
and in a society that
teaches us that our nature is to be
aggressive and competitive and
individualistic
and even suspicious of others
that goes against our nature
so we have to work our way through those
false beliefs
and come back to who really are which
are
connected beings really here to
to be both individuals to both to be
authentic and to be attached at the same
time so that there shouldn't be this
tragic tension between attachment and
authenticity we can be both authentic
and be connected
that's what we have to strive for both
as individuals and i think also as a
culture
when you think about wholeness
and
contending with these traumatic imprints
so you mentioned some say parenting
approaches that you disagree with
are there any
approaches or recommendations that you
think do more harm than good with
respect to
contending with trauma
or
moving towards wholeness
yeah any parenting practice or
educational practice that focuses on
behavior
rather than the child's underlying
emotional dynamics is going to be
harmful
because what we want
out of child rearing
is at the end of it there should be an
autonomous
human being respectful of themselves and
of others
who can be authentic and connected at
the same time that's our goal i don't
think anybody would disagree that that's
our goal for human beings now that's a
natural developmental process as long as
we provide the right conditions for it
but nothing in nature develops in the
wrong context so you know i could have
an acorn in my hand and the nature of
that acorn is to become an oak tree but
not if i leave it on my desk
right it needs you know water and soil
and sunlight and so on
a lot of planting and educational
practices focus not on the long-term
goal in development but on fixing the
kids behaviors in the short term
so
we talk about kids are acting out what
do you do when a kid acts out
well look at this phrase acting out what
does it mean to act something out
but when i say acting out when i say a
kid is acting out you will probably
think of a kid who's being oppositional
or or rude or disobedient or aggressive
but that's not what the phrase means
acting up means to portraying behavior
that which we haven't got the words to
say in language
so in a game of charades where you're
not allowed to speak
what do you have to do
you have to act it out act it out
if you landed in a country where nobody
spoke your language and you had to
portray hunger
you'd have to
act it out
kids are acting out their emotional
needs
the question is are we going to respond
to the child or want to try try and
suppress the behavior
so much of what's taught as parenting
advice is designed to manipulate or
shape or suppress kids behaviors
rather than understanding the
child and by the way this is also true
of adults as well as we look at human
beings and we don't see
what's really driving them we just
either approve or disapprove of
how they're behaving but we don't make
much of an effort the legal system
specializes in not understanding why
people behave the way they behave
just in suppressing it
which is why
in canada
where indigenous people make up five
percent of the population they make up
30 of the jail population
and uh indigenous women make up 50
percent of the female jail population in
this country it's an absolute scandal
same in the us
the more oppressed you are
the more marginalized you are the more
you've been traumatized by history
and you know which groups those are in
the united states the more you're going
to likely gonna have it in jail
because the legal system doesn't
understand
trauma
it doesn't understand human development
and it
confuses punishment with rehabilitation
so as a result
in terms of supporting healthy growth of
human beings at
any level we need understanding of
what's driving this behavior and it's
not a question of allowing bad behavior
or or permitting it or encouraging it
but it's a question of
what are we going to do about the
phenomena
of
aggression
or drug use
or
in the case of children
rudeness or disobedience or anything
else what are we going to do about it
are we going to try and just suppress
the behavior
then you end up where we are
with millions of people in jail
and lots of kids with learning
difficulties and and and behavior
problems and millions of kids being
medicated
or we're going to try and understand
what's happening what's driving it what
are the social cultural dynamics
that are
driving so much dysfunction
and it's not that hard to perceive we
have the science we have the research
we're just not applying it
let me hop in there a few things i want
to mention
that
come to mind as you're speaking
and then i'll i'll end it with a
question so the first is on the acting
out point how i've heard stories from a
number of friends and i don't have kids
so i get anyone out there don't look to
me for parenting advice but
with respect to baby sign teaching
children sign language before they
actually have the physiological
capability of speaking
that you reduce the amount of acting out
sort of crying for attention etc when
you enable them even with a handful
literally of
basic
sign language
symbols right hungry
thirsty
potty or whatever it might be
and
the so that makes sense to me the second
is and i like the way that you
deconstruct that phrase the second
as it relates to incarceration there's a
documentary i saw a long time ago
called the work
it's called the work it came out in 2017
at the very least everybody should watch
the trailer we'll link to it in the show
notes
and it relates to
effectively trauma work within
the prison system
um and i i say that as kind of in a
monolithic sense which might not be
perfectly accurate but with within a
prison in the united states and it's
absolutely
mesmerizing and brutal to watch and it
highlights how difficult it is
in the sense that you know an ounce of
prevention is is worth a pound of of
cure right
intervening early and but but let's look
at the adult case so coming back to this
trauma imprint if you were to take say
a thousand people from the population
kind of selected at random and they all
as adults pursued fixing their trauma
whatever they think of as that meaning
are there any approaches or
techniques or paths that you think are
risky damaging ill-advised
is there anything you'd like to
highlight in that department
well specifically in prisons in the u.s
i i
sounds this work that you mentioned
sounds wonderful i i know a couple of
other approaches
there's a film made about my work called
the wisdom of trauma that actually
people can watch online and there's a
scene in it i'm not involved but there's
a woman called fritzi horseman she's
wonderful you might want to talk to her
sometime she works with these
high level offenders and she's got these
large number of
people in this prison yard
standing in a circle all men and she
says
if you were hit regularly as a child
take a step forward everybody takes the
stuck in
if your parents yelled at you a lot take
a step in
if you abused take a step in
if you've witnessed violence in your
family origin take a step in and the
circle just keep getting smaller and
smaller and smaller as people kept keep
stepping in to the circle
and so she does wonderful trauma work in
it with prisoners and the
transformations are incredible
that she witnesses and helps to
facilitate
i know somebody else who works with
something called the prison enneagram
project now i you've probably heard it
with anna graham i've never studied it
i have it's come up with a number of
ceos yeah toby of shopify and others who
who use the enneagram it would be
helpful if you wanted to just give a
brief
overview or explain
what uh what you introduce
so i've never studied it though that
much
i don't know the
patience for it really it's a
personality typing
system
that allows you to look at potential
interactions of different people with
different typing and you can look at the
pros and cons of those interactions and
it's a lot more to it but those are some
of the basics yeah i think that's about
right and and also each enneagram type
has got its
potential values but also it's
shadow you know hazards
so i know somebody who's taken this work
into prisons and they do enneagram work
and i witnessed it
and these are these guys are killers
they've killed
it's hard to say this and it's gonna
draw some
maybe raised eyebrows or
skepticism from some of your listeners
these guys are the loveliest people in
the world
and they're not pretending
they were sensitive kids deeply
traumatized
nobody ever paid attention to them
everybody hurt them
very often of course minority status
somebody hears them allows them to work
with i quote one of them in the book
actually
and then he says if i ever get out of
here
all i ever want to do
is help people love themselves
because when i committed that crime
i was totally disconnected from myself i
didn't know who i was
i couldn't respect myself he says so i
couldn't respect no one else either
and as i've learned to respect myself
i now respect all human beings
they say i witnessed him saying this
this isn't san quentin actually
so the potential of of rehabilitation
and and bringing people back to
their human selves is enormous
given the right circumstances
but we know how punitive and how
traumatizing the prison experience is
for a lot of people because we equate
punishment rehabilitation it's not the
same thing so all i'm not saying that we
should allow murder or that we should
encourage crime what i'm saying is
if we apply the light of understanding
to what drives people
and we're actually interested in
rehabilitating them
so that the correctional system really
becomes a system that corrects people
rather than just punishes them
we could do so much with what we already
know and you know what
it wouldn't cost more it would cost less
yeah
you know for people interested i just
want to mention i actually did
some podcast interviews
behind the line inside a maximum
security prison in
california
at one point uh level four maximum
security prison current valley state
prison so people can find that 323
if they're interested in kind of getting
a peak behind the lines and
i would agree with you were you
surprised by anything
i was surprised by a lot because that is
certainly not my
native environment i mean on one hand
you had
violent events on a constant basis right
so there were real threats within
the prison and you know sort of riot
gear and so on had to be used
so you had tremendous potential for
violence and then you also had
tremendous potential
with the right help with the right
support and resources i was there
volunteering with a with a group
teaching entrepreneurial skills
uh because
without qualifications or
transferable skills to outside civilian
life
right
then the recidivism rate of course is
going to be very high also with
with felony or felonies on your record
it complicates the entire situation so
it's a very
very problematic
gnarly
puzzle to solve with taking people from
inside the system to then outside the
system and reintroducing them so that
was the context within which i was there
but we
were also able to have conversations
with people who had done a tremendous
job with support
of
rehabilitating themselves and really
using introspection
and
cultivated self-awareness to
turn their lives around even within the
confines of a maximum
security prison in some cases people who
were not eligible for parole right
people who were still turning their
lives around yeah despite the fact that
most likely they would be restricted to
life behind bars until they died
yeah
everything about it was
deeply impactful and
actually participated in a
an exercise that's very similar to the
one you described where people are
stepping forward or stepping backward
depending on
the things they've experienced and
when you start
when you start layering all of the
abuses and experiences these people have
suffered through i don't want to say
it's inevitable you know coming back to
the maybe the genetic comparison i think
it's not inevitable
that these people end up in jail but it
sets the conditions such that it is much
more likely especially if they're highly
sensitive as you mentioned
and
[Music]
it stuck with me it was very emotional
for me to witness honestly because i
grew up on long island
you know in family kind of lower middle
class with friends who
came from
some very tough households you know a
lot of alcoholism a lot of abuse a lot
of drugs and
some of my friends have not made it you
know some have died of opiate overdoses
and
drunk driving accidents etc and other
issues and
some are behind bars at this point also
and so it's also
striking to me how with one or two
different decisions
the trajectory of my life could have
very easily
gone in a direction that would have made
it more likely
that i would have ended up someplace
very very different
let me ask you if if you could no longer
write
you can no longer
i'll stick with writing you can't no
more no more writing
no more public speaking
but you are allowed to
focus on clinical practice
and this comes to mind because of what
this
this inmate you mentioned said about
spending the rest of his life doing
something yeah
what type of clinical practice
would you focus on
well i hope this rule against me
speaking isn't enacted very soon because
i got this multi-country trip lined up
that i'm really looking forward to but
so don't tell anybody okay that's
accepted yeah that's accepted okay but
it'd be much the same as i'm doing now
except more one-to-one it would be that
you come to me with an issue
and
i would help you to see that
there's nothing wrong with you
with you
with who you are
the stuff happened in your life
at a time when you couldn't help it
and you made a kind of meaning out of
that
like i made the meaning that i couldn't
be helped i couldn't be healed
or i made the meaning that i'm being
abandoned
and you made a certain meaning out of
that and you've been living your life
out of that meaning that you created at
a time when you had no choice in the
matter
and if you can get to be friends with
all those aspects of you
that
at that time
helped you survive
but now are creating suffering for you
and the people in your life
and if you can work your way back to
getting to know yourself and accepting
yourself
you'll be just fine
and whether your trauma shows up in a
form of multiple sclerosis
or rheumatoid arthritis
or
malignancy and by the way there's a lot
of literature linking all these
conditions to trauma so i'm not just
making this up
or whether it shows up as a rage or
whether it shows up as depression or as
adhd or as anything else
whether it shows up in
difficulty with intimacy in
in problems forming relationships
no matter how your problems manifest
there's a reason why they're there those
reasons can be understood dealt with
work through and you can find your way
back to yourself
so
that would be my clinical practice
almost no matter what people presented
with i say almost no matter what because
i don't be categorical about it
you're right there are some diseases
that are genetic one runs in my family
it's called muscular dystrophy if you
have the gene you're gonna have the
disease my mother had it my aunt had it
and they died with it
but that's very rare
very rare
for the most part
people we're dealing with the impacts of
life experience
in a culture that undermines
our connection to ourselves and to other
people
and that's what we have to
realize and and correct
well gubber
i know we could we could go and go and
go and go i mean i feel like that's a
powerful place to start to
maybe come to a close but i want to also
open the floor to anything else that you
might want to
mention uh any
thing you might want to add or if
apart from closing comments you might
have any requests of my audience
or suggestions to the audience
certainly the the new book is the myth
of normal i recommend people check it
out
i've seen you
you know through documentaries but also
you know in our interactions
in action so to speak and
i really respect you as a clinician
and a practitioner right not just a
theoretician
and
so i wanted to say that publicly
i'm aware of how much you've rolled up
your sleeves and worked with
very difficult cases of
addiction addiction and trauma
in some of the sort of highest density
areas in north america certainly with
respect to
all of these kind of intersecting
health challenges
so i wanted to say that but are there
any other
comments you'd like to add before we
bring this to a close
i'll tell you personally that
running this book has been the biggest
challenge of my life
at certain times i didn't know if i
would finish it or it would finish me
first because and
literally i went through panic at
certain times
i even became so desperate and that i
called a therapist and i had a therapy
session once a week
for several months in the middle of
writing the book which is a good thing
you know at least i was smart enough to
reach out for help you know
it was hard because i took on such a big
subject
which is the whole of this culture
and how that pertains to us as
individuals and as groups
but
what kept me going was this voice inside
me that's
that says you know
you
honestly you need to do this
but you're called to do this
and you wouldn't be being true to
yourself if you didn't fulfill the
calling
now
that voice
in one version another it
doesn't have to do with book writing or
any
other
project like that but that voice
who we are and and
what we can be in this world
that's inside all of us
and
there's such cacophony there's such
noise
generated by this culture
i mean the radio the tv the internet is
yelling at you 24 7.
and we're being pulled away from
ourselves in so many ways
but the bible talks about the small
still voice that's inside of us and
the noise around us generated by this
culture makes that voice almost
impossible to hear
but i'm sure you've had the experience
yourself and a lot of people have
it's in there and
if we can just listen to it
so
that was my biggest takeaway from
writing this book is
and i'm so glad i did it and in the end
i'm just so happy with
what i've been able to set down on paper
but by the way with the brilliant help
of my son daniel i couldn't have done
this on my own
and uh if i can pitch forward a bit the
next book dialogue writing is called
hello again a fresh start for adult
children and their parents
maybe in a few years when that's done
that's the workshop that we do and maybe
in a few years i can come back and talk
to you again when that book comes out
sure let's do it but anyway the long and
short of it is
that
the lesson that i derived is that
it's not easy to listen to that voice
but it's
a essential and be so rewarding and that
voice is inside all of us
so i have to
follow up
because this is touching a nerve for me
right now because i've been sort of
sitting
in the silence for about a year and a
half now i've not committed to any large
projects
do you have any advice for
attuning to or sensitizing
to picking out
that small still voice
because uh
i would love to maybe have a more
acute
ability
to
observe that
not that i'm totally deaf dumb and blind
but do you have any any recommendations
i do
but are you willing for a bit of an
experiment right now
oh man here we go again
okay i may end up being the pinata but
i'll go with it yes i'm open to it okay
oh that's gonna happen and you know it's
just an experiment and it may or may not
work and it's really okay if it doesn't
so there's no
i'm not gonna feel like a failure if it
doesn't work and
you won't be getting a failing grade if
nothing comes up it's just an experiment
right all right
let's try it
so you say you've been kind of
observing some degree of silence and not
committing to long-term projects very
wise
because something inside you needs to
work yourself out and you're giving it
space
and uh so i'm just gonna ask you to just
be
silent for a moment within yourself
and
then i'm going to ask you a question i'm
going to snap my fingers ask a question
i snap my fingers just say the first
thing that comes to your mind
if anything does and if nothing does
that's really okay but whatever you do
don't try and think about it okay so
don't try and figure out the right
answer there's no right answer okay
we're just gonna see if anything comes
up or not
so
i might ask two questions okay so
just silence for a moment okay
you're paying attention to what's
happening inside you
your chest your belly your head you know
you're just being present with yourself
i'm going to ask you what's calling you
uh animals
animal communication
okay
that's the first thing that comes up
okay well
i don't know what that means but i'm
sure you do
yeah
okay
great
by the way animals have a lot to tell us
don't they
yeah
it's not true that i don't know what you
know
i know people that work with horses
i don't know exactly what you mean but i
know there's a lot there
okay so if that comes up for you then
the second question would be what's
stopping you
uh what's you know i think what's
stopping me is i don't know how to
i can pursue it i am actually
going to be pursuing that in the next
month especially because i got a
sort of a very promising lead okay
involving
some indigenous animal trackers okay
so that's a whole separate story but
i am unsure of how to
because
i i'm
sort of on the periphery of this
interest right and the interest i i
think is very much
an attraction to
non-verbal
forms of communication
so that could be humans but i just find
the kind of pure unadulterated
naturally selected
manifestation of that is seen so clearly
in
animals and what about that ability
there's something about that appeals to
you what's the appeal there for you
in a word
in a word oh
give me a second i'll have to
do a little search function for a word
you know comes up for me
what comes up for you purity
yeah i think for me it would be very
close right i was i was going to say
i mean it's cheating it's not
a word but
other
means of knowing
then knowing okay knowing that like
other means of knowing right so
forget the other means it's knowing yeah
and you don't want that knowing
happening through the intellect
yeah i don't want it going through a
bunch of filters and abstractions and
concepts i think it just gets so clumsy
yeah so look
damn it sounds to me like you're
got a beautiful calling
which is pure knowing
and you even have a
pathway that you've envisioned which is
through animal communication
i think you're on your way i don't think
there's a big mystery here
well you know i'm gonna borrow i'm gonna
borrow that that confidence if i may you
know i'll i'll kind of fake it until i
make it here with that i'm i'm excited
thank you for doing the exercise
[Music]
you know hopefully people
yeah maybe they had a chance to try
themselves
i i'm excited about i think there's part
of me that is trying to force it into
this maybe false construct of
uh
a job if that makes any sense and just
bear with me as i try to walk through
this like right now i do the podcast i
love doing the podcast it's basically
they're interviews but i'm also very
self-indulgent with turning them into my
own therapy sessions so thanks for
playing along
and
there's part of me that really enjoys
a commitment to all-consuming projects
because
i find it so much easier to say no to
the noise and to the temptations and the
shiny objects
when i have a clear focus that consumes
much of my days or all of my days
and
maybe it's just premature but i've i've
been trying to figure out all right well
how does this interest actually
translate to something that i can spend
that amount of time on
and the answer is not forthcoming so
i i think for that reason i've hesitated
in taking the plunge which is probably
silly well what if i may say you're
trying to bargain with your authenticity
here
you know and it seems to me you're
trying to justify it somehow you know
like
for me to be authentic and pursue this
calling i have to somehow
translate it into some
monetized or professionally acceptable
or respectable endeavor
i don't imagine that financially or
constrained to do that oh no yeah it's
not the finances it's
more like how do i make it something i
don't want it to be a
disrespected
hobby if that makes sense like it's it's
something i feel very drawn to respect
so i'm sorry don't drop but are you
worried what other people will think
about it
no no i'm not i'm not actually i'm
worried that i won't have enough to chew
on for it to
sustain me for
a period of time i just won't have
i won't be able to sink my teeth into it
enough to spend what i would view as
a critical mass of time to reach some
point of
like expertise but no that that's all
internal it doesn't have anything to do
with what other people think okay great
so
you want to be able to respect it enough
with inside yourself but look what's the
worst case scenario you hear to me when
i hear you speak about it then you said
a few words you said
animal communication
you said
knowing
pure annoying i would call it
to me that's very inspiring that you'd
be
caught by that it really is from the
outside just to tell you how i respond
to it that's boy this guy's really got
something here you know that's what i'm
thinking and what's the worst case
scenario is that you take the next step
with this indigenous
possibility that you mentioned
and you'll see it won't you
you know yeah right do you have to
figure it out all in advance or can you
just take the next step and trust the
process
yeah
the answer is i can
trust the process you know anyway
it makes me think of i can't remember
who said it but uh you know they're like
somebody described writing a novel as
driving across the country
in the dark with only headlights to
guide you it's like you you can get
there you can make it from one side to
the other but you can only see
100 feet in front of you at any given
point in time
so i think i probably just
need to sort of take
take that and uh and run with it so
thank you thank you i will uh i'm gonna
be i already have a couple of things on
the calendar in the next
two months that i'm really excited about
so
right i think i just need to stop
dipping my toe in the water and really
get in i would say one final thing is
that the mind that we develop as kids in
response to trauma
doesn't trust their authenticity very
much
for a good reason
because authenticity will get us into
trouble
so
i would suggest that quite possibly some
of the self-questioning and hesitation
and the
the diet around it
is still a bit of a
an echo
where you are programmed to question
your authenticity because what you're
talking about sounds very authentic to
me
yeah it could be
that wouldn't surprise me yeah i mean i
think that's uh as good a theory as any
for me to
to recognize is is valid at this point
so thanks for the thanks for the
encouragement i appreciate it well i'm
just reflecting what i'm seeing that's
all well thank you for the reflection
i look forward to learning how that goes
for you one way the other actually
yeah me too me too well gobbler thank
you so much for the time it's nice to
see you again
and
it has been it feels doesn't feel that
long ago that we sat face to face in
austin but it's been quite a while
remarkably so
and you have been busy i'm very excited
about the new book
and for people who would like to check
it out and i encourage they check it out
the new book is the myth of normal
trauma illness and healing in a toxic
culture you can find more information on
the book at dr gabor mate.com that's
dr.gabourmate.com
and you can find gabriel on twitter at
dr dr gabriel mate and then on instagram
gabrielmate
md
and
we've covered a lot of ground and
i
really appreciate you being such an open
book and also maybe helping me to turn a
few pages in the process so much
appreciated
gabor thank you for making the time
thank you it's a pleasure
take care
you